Et bien bonjour comment allez-vous ?
Cette intro n'a rien à voir avec mon chien ;-)
mais vu que je suis complètement gaga et attardé aussi, je la fais avec lui.
*musique de thug*
Les amis, aujourd'hui on va jouer à un petit jeu narratif
ça fait longtemps qu'on n'a pas joué à un jeu narratif.
La dernière fois on avait joué à quoi ? Un jeu euh.. ah oui fallait séduire une meuf et on avait réussi totalement
"Hoo t'es mon nouveau meilleur ami !
*musique* #friendzoned
"My heart is broken."</3 Mon coeur est brisé
Pourquoi je voulais jouer à ce jeu ?
Déjà parce qu'il coûte 3,50 euros et c'est pas très cher, c'est plutôt rentable pour faire une vidéo.
*rire* Et la vraie raison surtout
c'est qu'il parle d'un sujet qui me tient un peu à cœur à savoir l'immigration.
Alors, les développeurs se sont inspirés d'un article de "Le Monde" qui est incroyable !
On va suivre l'aventure d'une migrante syrienne qui veut atteindre l'Allemagne.
C'est un article incroyable, je mettrai le lien dans la description si vous voulez, allez voir ça.
C'est riche en émotions, c'est très bien fait ! Bravo à la journaliste qui a fait ça.
Le jeu là c'est assez simple, on va devoir aider une syrienne à atteindre l'Allemagne
en lui donnant des conseils et tout ça juste à travers une conversation Whatsapp.
Elle va nous décrire les situations dans lesquelles elle est.
On va avoir plusieurs choix de réponses pour l'aider
et ce sera à nous de prendre les bonnes décisions, y'a 20 fins différentes je crois.
On va voir laquelle on va avoir.
Nous, on a la chance de vivre dans un pays développé, où il n'y a pas de conflits comme ça.
On doit pas fuir de notre pays à cause d'une guerre.
Du coup là on va un peu de prendre la réalité dans la gueule et je sais très bien que ça va me faire quelque chose
mais là je suis prêt, aujourd'hui je suis dans un mood euh de jeu scénarisé alors on y va.
30 septembre 2015, 10h32.
"Majd, j'ai entendu des bombes ! Est-ce que ça va ?"
"Oui Allah soit loué ça va. Je suis au magasin, et toi ?"
"Toujours à l'hôpital."
hooo.. non
Un jeu co-produit par "The Pixel Hunt", bravo à The Pixel Hunt qui a d'ailleurs reçu pleins de prix pour ce jeu.
1 octobre
"D'abord maman, puis Amin, puis Tarek qui se barre je ne sais pas où et maintenant Nawal..."
"Comment va-t-elle?"
"état critique, elle est en réa. Je te jure Majd si elle s'en sort pas je me barre d'ici..
l'Europe, les états-Unis, la Chine, n'importe où, je m'en fous. Tout sauf Homs, tout sauf la Syrie."
Bon voilà, l'intro qui nous met déjà bien en condition quoi, sur ce que c'est de vivre là-bas.
C'est parti !
Nour, 4 mars.
Oh une petite photo !
On la télécharge.
C'est Nour, qui a un sac à dos. Est-ce qu'elle est en train de partir ?
Ok donc là on peut répondre qu'un truc.
"Déjà arrivée au rendez-vous?"
"Ouais mais le taxi n'est pas là."
ça commence mal
Tu es en avance.
Oh on va dire " Tu es en avance"  on va pas être dans la négation, on va pas la stresser. Faut toujours être positif.
"Dire que j'étais stressée d'être en retard. Par contre, je suis persuadée d'avoir oublié quelque chose."
On va mettre un petit smiley, plutôt que de répondre Ouais mais si tu t'y prenais pas au dernier moment aussi nanania
C'est pas le moment !
"Dis-moi juste si il manque un truc.
Le passeport, le billet d'avion et le visa pour la Turquie,
le chargeur, sweat, jean et t-shirt de rechange, trousse de 1er secours + de toilette"
Alors qu'est ce qu'il lui manque ? On a le choix entre une batterie de rechange ou du déodorant.
Du déo, si tu sens bon, les gens seront plus gentils avec toi et ce sera bien.. Pire théorie.
"Vas y, dis que je pue !"
*rire* ^^
On lui envois un petit smiley qui tire la langue.
"Ah !"
Il y a Denis qui a volé son téléphone tiens.
"C'est bon je crois que je vois mon taxi. Merde."
Quoi merde ?!
"Le chauffeur parle d'échanges de tirs à la frontière."
"Est-ce que la route est bloquée ?"
"Il ne sais pas mails il demande 25 000 de plus pour m'amener à Beyrouth, prime de risque, il dit."
Ha le batard !!!
"Sinon pour les 25 000 de départ il dit qu'il peut m'amener à Damas pour prendre un bus."
Ok, qu'est ce qu'on fait ? Est-ce qu'on l'emmène à Beyrouth ou à Damas ?
Putain !
Bon on va lui demander son avis.
"Je pense que j'ai l'impression qu'il essaie de m'arnaquer mais que j'ai pas vraiment envie de me prendre une balle perdue sur une impression.
Tu veux pas regarder si ils disent quelque chose aux infos ?"
Ok vas y ouais t'as raison. On va voir si il ya vraiment des échanges vénères.
"Ils parlent d'affrontement ce matin. J'arrive pas à voir si ça continue."
MERDE PUTAIN ! ho lala le premier choix du jeu me met en PLS mon gars ! Le premier !
"Bon je crois je vais tenter Damas alors."
Non non non mauvaise idée, "si tu fais ça tu risques de rater ton vol." ouais ouais non non et puis c'est risqué  mais...
Putain fais chier de merde là !!
"ça vaaa il est que demain matin, ça devrait le faire. Et puis le bus me coûtera toujours moins que ce petit supplément"
Ah elle, elle a vraiment envie d'aller à Damas quoi. Elle veut pas passer par la frontière où il y a des échanges de tirs.
ce que je peux tout à fait comprendre.
Non on colle au plan je sens que Damas ça va être le plan foireux. Il y a un plan qui a été établi je pense qu'il faut pas qu'on le change.
Je sens qu'à Damas mon gars ça va être la merde, il va y avoir que des imprévus. Je le sens !
"Je gère, OK ?"
Ah ouais non ok en fait j'ai pas le choix quoi, c'est un faux choix.
La meuf elle est à fond dans son truc.
"Ok comme tu veux"
Je veux pas t'énerver.
"Merde, merde merde merde merde merde"
Quoi ?
"Y'a pas de bus !"
" Enfin si, mais pas avant demain 5h"
"Et l'avion est à qu'elle heure ?"
"10H15"
Ok dans ce genre de situation faut juste pas paniquer et rester droit.
MAIS JE TE L'AVAIS DIT QU'A DAMAS C'ETAIT LA MERDE PUTAIN NOUR.
ça va, ça va..
Je pense que c'est serré, après je ne sais pas à quelle distance sont les deux villes mais..
"ça pourrait passer"
"Oui mais le moindre incident et c'est foutu"
Exactement.
"D'accord mais qu'est ce que je peux faire alors ?"
On verra demain ou alors reprend le taxi.
Franchement reprend le taxi ! Il faut que t'atteignes Beyrouth.
"Ca coûtera toujours moins cher que de rater l'avion."
C'est bien ça, c'est bien, j'aime bien ce mec.
"C'est bon il arrive. Il demande encore 25 000 livres"
Ah le petit batard !
"Bon je suis limite niveau batterie là je vais couper le tel un moment."
"Ok à toute"
Ho lala, putain, dès le début ça me tend alors que c'est la première étape d'un long voyage, y'a pleins d'étapes.
"Bonsoir"
"Enfin ! Où es tu ?"
"Beyrouth, dans un hôtel"
Ouiii, tu vois tu t'es pas pris de balles !
" J'ai compté au moins 6 cafards avant d'arriver à la chambre."
haaa !
"Ha et tu devineras jamais qui j'ai croisé, Camilia !"
"C'est qui Camilia ?"
"Mais si tu sais la femme de Mohammed !"
"C'est qui Mohammed ?"
"Ton cousin, ils étaient là à notre mariage !"
Ho la, attends le mec il a pas l'air d'avoir un cousin qui s'appelle Mohammed c'est quoi cette discussion bizarre là.
"C'est pas mon cousin, on était ensemble à l'université."
Mais voilà aussi Nour, dis pas des bêtises.
"Mohammed il est en Europe !"
wow, il a réussi à passer !?
Attends là on a de l'espoir, ça nous donne beaucoup d'espoir cette histoire.
"Il a fait la traversée en bateau
"Et là il attend d'obtenir l'asile en Angleterre. Camilia m'a donné son nouveau numéro pour que je puisse lui demander des conseils."
On avait dit Istanbul parce que la traversée nous faisais peur mais si Mohammed a des contacts de passeurs c'est peut-être le plus simple du coup ?"
Ha lala, j'aime pas changé les plans à la dernière minute, je suis tellement pas partisan de ça c'est terrible !
"Si ça se trouve il a juste eu beaucoup de chance"
"J'ai hâte que tu me rejoignes"
Hoo ils s'aiment et tout. Aller aller ça va aller vous allez réussir !
On va tomber sur la fin heureuse où ils ont des bébés, et les enfants vont à l'école pendant qu'eux ils sont PDG d'une grande entreprise.
"C'est la première nuit que je passe loin de toi, ça fait bizarre."
Tiens une petite photo regarde.. On t'envoie une petite photo
"Tu m'enregistres des ronflements aussi ?"
Hooo c'est mignon !
Ok deux jours plus tard le 5 mars.
Aller j'espère qu'elle va pouvoir rentrer dans l'avion, il va pas avoir un problème à la douane ou je sais pas quoi.
"Oui salle d'embarquement je voulais pas te réveiller"
Alors est-ce que l'avion a du retard ou pas, c'est ça qu'on veut savoir, est-ce que tout se passe bien ? Dis nous Nour, rassure nous !
"Non, Tout va bien"
NICKEL !
"Ca me fait juste bizarre de savoir que dans 4 heures j'aurai changé de continent. On se reparle à mon arrivée"
"Parfait"
Elle nous fait le smiley bisous coeur qu'on apprécie tant.
"J'ai une réponse de Mohammed, il m'a filé le contact du passeur qui l'a fait traverser à Izmir
et donné le nom du quartier où il faut aller, Basmane ça s'appelle"
Wow Putain attends faut résonner. Selon vous c'est quoi le mieux ? C'est de faire "clac Bim" par la mer ou "clac Bim" par la terre ?
La mer les bateaux ils sont blindés à tout moment ils risquent de coulés alors que la terre ça paraît un peu plus safe
mais est-ce qu'il y a pas un peu plus de contrôle au niveau de la terre qu'au niveau de la mer ?
Je sais pas !!
On lui dit "Laisse tomber, suis le plan"
Ouais non mais je pense c'est le mieux. Je pense faut pas changer le plan vraiment !
Aller bon vol Nour ! Envole toi bien, amuse toi bien !
Ok on a des news, elle est arrivée en Turquie. Elle est à Kumkapi.
"Le chauffeur de la navette m'a déposée là sans que je ne demande rien, je crois que je commence à comprendre pourquoi
il n'y a pas un seul truc ici, que des africains, des migrants ou des touristes
j'étais à peine sortie que 10 mecs me sont tombé dessus pour me vendre des cartes Sims ou m'emmener dans des call-shops."
Méfie-toi hein, attention.
On vient de lui dire de cacher son argent parce que là-bas ils savent qu'il y a des gens qui ont de la tune sur eux
pour pouvoir atteindre l'Europe et du coup ils se font volés. Donc il faut qu'elle trouve une astuce.
On lui dit dans la doublure ou dans les chaussures ?
Dans la doublure c'est mieux que les chaussures
Ha mais si tu perds ta veste ?
Non mais tu vas pas perdre ta veste !
Pourquoi ça s'éteint ça ?
Dans une doublure c'est pas mal.
Dans les chaussures c'est trop classique.
"Quelque chose que tu portes toujours sur toi."
Ouais voilà c'est bien ça.
"Je peux défaire les coutures de mon soutien gorge."
"Maintenant ?"
"Bah non, là il est sur moi mais je peux trouver une aiguille, du fil et des toilettes dans l'après-midi."
Ok très bien ! Très bien !
Alors, bon là il est... faut que tu le cache un peu mieux quand même hein.
"Des gens m'ont abordée pour tout un tas de trucs.. mais pas de passeurs."
Merde
"Je crois que c'est plus dans une ville qui s'appelle Edirne que ça se passe"
ho la c'est loin !
Putain, elle est là et il faut qu'elle aille là !
Est-ce qu'on lui dit d'attendre ce soir ou d'y aller maintenant ?
Vas y en plein jour hein. Moi je dis vas y en plein jour.
"J'ai pas envie de rester ici de toute façon. Je parle pas la langue, je connais personne et je le sens pas ce quartier."
Ok, suis ton instinct.
Elle est pas contente ! Putain il s'est passé quoi ?
"Pétage de câble, ils veulent pas me vendre de billets pour Edirne !"
"Mais t'as un visa t'as quand même le droit de te déplacer en Turquie ?"
"Oui mais pas trop près des frontières apparemment."
Putain ! J'en étais sûr que la terre ça allait faire chier au niveau des frontières !
"Essaie un autre guichet !"
"Parce que tu crois que j'ai pas essayé ?"
Je ne sais pas Nour ! Parle moi autrement Nour s'il te plaît !
Enfin ! J'essaye de t'aider voyons !
"Je suis allée voir 3 mecs et une nana, je l'ai joué la polie, j'ai crié, j'ai même fait mes yeux de chien battu"
Oh non tes yeux de chien battu Nour, ça marche à chaque fois.
"Bah résultat ils me disent tous la même chose : "No Turkish, No ticket."
En plus, le bus est juste là, je pourrais grave tenter de monter quand même..."
Non non, c'est la pire chose.
Ha putain je ne sais pas..
Est-ce qu'on y va au culot ?
Tu monte dans le bus sans ticket...
ouais mais tu vas te faire contrôlée, ils vont te jeté, tu vas finir en prison ou je sais pas où..
Non fais pas ça.
"Si la police te tombe dessus, visa ou pas visa, tu risques d'avoir des problèmes."
Ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais...
"Y'a un quartier d'Istanbul surnommé Little Syria.
C'est peut-être un bon endroit pour commencer à chercher."
Ok, je lui ai conseillé de chercher un restaurant, quelque part où elle peut rencontrer des mecs.
Pour lui donner des bons tuyaux.
"Je suis dans une sorte de sallon de thé/ librairie / salle de concert."
D'accord le truc ambidextre à 100 %.
"En tout cas les gens sont super sympa, ils ont l'habitude d'accueillir les voyageurs syriens.
Déjà ils m'ont confirmé que les bus c'était mort vu qu'ils laissent monter que les turcs.
Mais du coup il y a des passeurs qui peuvent me conduire d'ici à Edirne, après faut passer la frontière à pied. Mohammad connait quelqu'un."
Ouiiiii. Il est super stylé !
Excellent, j'ai confiance en cet homme !
Ok, elle va dormir ans une chambre d'hôte et là elle veut profiter de sa soirée.
Ok, esperons que ça se soit bien passé!
"Je suis avec Mohammad là et son ami le passeur."
Haa ! Une bonne nouvelle ça !
"Il dit qu'il connait les bons endroits à la frontière bulgare. Il m'emmène là-bas, il me laisse traverser toute seule et je paye que si j'arrive de l'autre côté."
C'est bien ça !
"En fait je laisse l'argent à Mohammad et si j'arrive de l'autre côté, je lui envoie un message pour qu'il le donne au passeur.
et sinon il me garde le au chaud à Istanbul."
Quoi ?
Mais Mohammad tu le connais depuis 12 heures ?
Qu'est ce que tu veux lui confier l'argent et lui donner le rôle du mec qui le donne au passeur si la traversée à marché où pas ?
Si ça se trouve le passeur c'est juste un complice de Mohammad et ils arnaquent tous les syriens qui passent par là !
Mais enfin Nour, voyons !
"Je comprends ce que tu veux dire mais je pense que je peux faire confiance à Mohammad, il a déjà aidé plein de gens ! "
"Qu'est ce que tu en sais ?"
Mais c'est vrai Nour, fais gaffe !
Il y a des humains qui sont fourbes hein !
"Tout ça pour dire que MOI je lui fais confiance, tu peux me faire confiance à MOI ?"
Ok...
"On parle de combien du coup ?"
Aller combien ça coûte alors ?
1500...
C'est honnête ou c'est trop cher ?
Mais mec qu'est-ce que j'en sais ! J'ai aucune valeur des choses sur ça !
Le seule problème c'est qu'une fois que tu es à Edirne, tu es encore loin de l'Allemagne..
Il te restera 1200 pour tout ça.. j'ai du mal à y croire.
"Bon, de toute façon le départ n'est pas avant ce soir, ça laisse le temps de se renseigner ailleurs."
Ok, ouais vois toutes les options avant.
"Osman peut pas se soir finalement..."
Noon !
"Ca voiture doit être pleine... j'aurais du lui dire oui Majd !"
Ho merde j'ai déconné !
Ok, l'après-midi est passé. Elle nous dit qu'elle n'a pas trouvé mieux que le plan de Mohammad.
Donc on va juste prier pour que demain Osman nous emmène.
Ho la la, attends attends ! Nour, elle nous fait une phase là !
Elle a passé sa soirée avec Mohammad et tout dans le cabaret je sais pas quoi,
elle écrit comme une meuf bourrée, elle dit "à ce porpos" au lieu de dire propos,
elle double les lettres, ça faut pas être inspecteur Squeezie pour comprendre qu'il y a de l'alcool la dedans..
et elle nous dit :
"Et si j'y allais pas ?"
Qu'est ce qu'il t'arrive là ?
"Et si je restais là en Syrie ?"
"En Turquie tu veux dire ?"
Elle est complètement bourrée, l'alcool est dangereux pour la santé ! On l'a pas assez répété à Nour !
"Nour tu as bu ?"
"Oui"
*rire*
Elle est honnête, j'aime bien.
"Un peu"
Ha, elle est un peu malhonnête, j'aime moins.
"Je te rappelle que c'est contraire à TA religion, pas la mienne ! Je suis athée moi."
Ok, elle part en discours de meuf bourrée là, c'est insupportable.
"Je préfère encore dormir que de discuter avec quelqu'un de pas marrant."
Hoo, elle lui en met plein la tête. Le pauvre..
Vous avez vu comme c'est horrible de parler avec quelqu'un de bourré quand toi tu n'es pas bourré.
C'est la pire chose et dans la vraie vie c'est encore pire !
" Coucou"
"Madame fais la grasse matinée."
Ha putain 11h40 tu as bien dodo !
Alors est-ce que ce soir tu vas pouvoir passer ? Dis nous Nour !
Ok, elle a rendez-vous avec le passeur dans 8 heures donc à 19h40.
Et elle a oublié de mettre son téléphone a charger hier soir.
Hoo mais noon putain !
Le moment où ça va coupé mec on va être en PLS on aura plus de nouvelles.
ça va coupé au moment où elle va partir avec le passeur, c'est sûr !
"C'est bon je sais je vais le laisser à la librairie en attendant, je viens le chercher après."
On va te le voler ! haa !
Ok, le lendemain!
Ho putain, on n'a pas eu de nouvelles jusqu'au lendemain.
"Bon bah voilà, je suis en voiture."
Ho YES !!
Voyons voir si elle arrive à passer maintenant.
Ho putain, elle vient d'arriver !
"Le turc nous a lâché dans la forêt, maintenant il faut marcher."
Ouais, passez cette frontière !
Passez cette frontière !
*rire*
"Ca va aller ?"
"Je ne sais pas."
Hooo..
"On voit que dalle.
Hoo...
"Rah merde je viens de me ramasser par terre."
NON !
"Pas super malin d'écrire en marchant dans le noir, bon excuse mais du coup faut pas que je perde les autres."
Ouais, suis les de près, ouais ouais..
Ne me répond pas, ne me répond pas.
Ok, 2 heures plus tard elle nous envois ça :
"Test"
"Je voulais voir si j'avais encore du réseau."
Tu es passée ou pas ??
Hoo non il y a un problème !
"Zineb veut faire une pause. Nahid ça va, il a 12 ans, il trotte. Mais elle, elle galère avec le bébé.
Le problème c'est qu'Emmanuel est déjà loin devant. Et comme on ne peut pas crier.."
Ho putain ! Qu'est ce qu'on fait ?
Est-ce qu'elle rejoint Emmanuel qui est un grand baraqué ou est-ce qu'elle reste avec Zineb et son bébé ?
Putain..
*rire*
Je ne sais pas !!
Franchement, si c'était dans la vraie vie je me serais dit il y a ma meuf qu'est hyper loin de moi,
elle est au milieu d'une forêt, il fait nuit, elle est en train de passer une frontière,
Franchement, rattrape Emmanuel ma puce !
*rire*
Je veux que tu survives !
"Mais je peux pas les laisser !"
Hoo c'est horrible horrible !! La pire chose !
"J'ai rattrapé Emmanuel. Je me déteste"
"Tu dois d'abord penser à toi."
C'est horrible mais c'est vrai quoi. Là faut vraiment quoi.
"Emmanuel va vite, il faut que je te laisse, je te raconterai tout demain."
Suis le ! C'est un bonhomme cet Emmanuel !
Hoo la ! Ok. Donc c'était à 6 heures son dernier message.
à 21 heures on lui demande des nouvelles !
30 heures sans nouvelles !! Alors, est-ce que ça va ?
"ça va, tout va bien."
*soulagement*
Elle a passé la frontière ? Dis moi oui !
"Mieux que ça je suis à Sofia."
Hooo !
Ouiii !
On a fait la moitié du chemin mon gars !
"Désolée de pas t'avoir contacté avant, tout est allé super vite.
On vient de se poser pour la première fois dans un hôtel pourri mais y'a des prises et du Wi-Fi.
Je suis toujours avec Emmanuel."
Très bien !! J'adore cet Emmanuel !
"Il a pas d'argent alors on partage la chambre."
Ha c'est plus mon pote, je le déteste vraiment !
"On était encore en train de redescendre dans la forêt quand on a entendu des chiens aux loin mais pas trop loin.
Emmanuel m'a aidé à monter dans un arbre mais lui a pas eu le temps avant que les mecs arrivent.
C'était pas la police, pas l'armée non plus. Juste des mecs. Je comprenais rien à ce qu'ils disaient
mais ils avaient l'air vénères. Moi j'ai passé le reste de la nuit dans l'arbre.
Je suis redescendue quand il a commencé à faire jour, j'ai continué tout droit et je suis retombée sur Emmanuel en train de boîter.
Il avait réussi à échapper aux mecs mais pas trop aux chiens. Ils lui ont déchiré le mollet."
MERDE  !!
"J'ai fait ce que je pouvais comme bandage, on a continué à marcher jusqu'à trouver une sorte de parking.
Il y avait un pickup avec une bâche, on s'est mis sous la bâche et on a attendu en espérant que quelqu'un arrive et conduise ce truc vers le nord.
c'est ce qui s'est passé. On est descendus à Sofia. Jusqu'à présent je tenais avec l'adrénaline mais là je sens que tout mon corps lâche."
Repose-toi à l'hôtel. Fais une bonne nuit de 10 heures là Bim !
"Désolée de pas trop avoir la force de discuter."
C'est pas grave. On s'en fout.
C'est Emmanuel !!
On est loin de Macron.
Alors vous faites quoi là ?
"A une station service. On a passé la frontière serbe, j'ai fait deux courses et acheté une SIM.
J'ai pas trop le temps de t'expliquer, on va repartir bientôt.
Mais en gros on a trouvé un camion pour passer la frontière et nous amener à Belgrade."
Quel genre de camion ?
"C'est pas vraiment un camion en fait.. tu vois les remorques pour transporter chevaux ?"
*rire* ça fera le travail.
"Bien arrivé à Belgrade."
Ok.
"Ils ont affrété des bus à Indija, ça se dispute pour ssavoir s'il faut les prendre ou non.
Plein de gens ne peuvent déjà plus marcher."
Ha merde !
"ça ressemble à quoi si on s'arrête maintenant ? Déjà que la moitié des gens sont déjà dans le bus. Emmanuel compris.."
Ho non ! Emmanuel l'a lâchée..
"Il préfère tenter sa chance par la Croatie."
Elle nous a envoyé une petite photo..
Ils sont ensemble, ils sont posés.
Motivez vous les uns les autres !
"Comment tu me trouves ?"
"Tu es magnifique."
Tu es vraiment la lumière qui illumine mais jours ensoleillés sous la prairie des brumes endiablées...
"Je ressemble à un sac à patates."
Mais naan..
un sac carrefour peut-être
Ho la la ça part en couilles son truc. Tout le monde commence à s''engueuler et toutes les familles partent pour la Croatie
au lieu d'atteindre la Hongrie comme prévu initialement.
Merde !
"On a trouvé une carte sur internet avec des zones rouges là où il y a le moins de surveillance à la frontière."
Il reste le tiers du groupe ! Putain, ils sont plus que 100 au lieu de 300.
"C'est pas sûr qu'on tienne encore un jour de marche."
Aller courage Nour courage !!
"On va s'arrêter là pour la nuit. On devrait passer à la frontière demain midi."
Ok.
"Je crois qu'on est plus loin de la frontière. Pas de barbelés, pas de police, rien !
ça va être facile."
Soit prudente attends, il y a peut-être un piège.
4 heures plus tard : " et ben les champs de mine c'est plus ce que c'était, on est tous entiers !"
Nooouuuur !!
Mais il faut pas que tu te prennes une mine !
"C'est ce que je disais : les zones pas surveillées."
ho non. Mais c'est risqué là quand même.
"On a trouvé une station service, on va pourvoir faire le plein !"
Ho vous avez une voiture ??
"Le plein de batterie banane !"
Haaaaaa !
"Et d'eau, on a plus d'eau."
Ca c'est embêtant ça.
Aller courage Nour ! T'y es presque ! Plus qu'un pays à passer.
"Je pense qu'on va essayer de faire du stop."
Alors, on a le choix, soit on lui conseille de chercher les plaques étrangères,
soit d'aller vers les camions.
euuuuuh..
Va vers les camions, c'est bien les camions.
"J'ai trouvé un chauffeur. Un camionneur."
Et bah voilà putain ! Mais oui mais c'est ça les bonnes décisions !
"Majd Majd Majd Majd !"
Quoi ?
"Je vais en Allemagne."
Quoi ?!
Non !?
Ibrahim le chauffeur, quand je lui ai expliqué que je voulais aller en Allemagne, il m'a sorti genre :
"Bah pourquoi tu l'as pas dit plutôt, je vais jusqu'à Munich moi." "
NON !
"Il n'a pas peur de se faire arrêter aux frontières ?"
"Bah écoute, j'ai préféré ne pas en parler, des fois que ça le ferait changer d'avis.
Mais je pense qu'il est pas con non plus.
On va bientôt arriver en Slovénie."
Putain ça va tellement vite, ça s'accélère
"On s'approche du péage de la frontière, je vais passer à l'arrière.
Ouais.
"Eeeet, on est repassé devant."
Putain ça s'accélère là.
"Tu as eu du bol quand même de tomber sur Ibrahim, normalement les gens font payer pour faire passer les frontières ."
OUI ! Et c'est d'ailleurs très bizarre !
Je me demande s'il n'y a pas anguille sous roche.
"Je crois que je n'ai pas encore bien réalisé que d'ici 3-4 heures je serai en Allemagne."
Putain, je sens la merde... c'est trop facile là.
"Majd, comment on dit prise électrique en allemand ?"
Ha non, elle est en Autriche, elle est en Autriche et sans batterie.
"Je suis descendue du camion."
POURQUOI ?! Il devait t'amener à Munich !
"Ibrahim m'a mis la main sur la cuisse, alors j'ai piqué une crise jusqu'à ce qu'il arrête le camion. Voilà."
Haa !
Je l'avais dit en plus tout à l'heure que les camionneurs ils étaient des fois.. attention hein le clichés.
Ok, elle est pas très loin de Viennes, dans une chambre d'hôtes dans un bled qui s'appelle Seeboden.
Putain t'as plus qu'une frontière de merde avant d'atteindre l'Allemagne.
"Je viens de monter dans une voiture là, je voulais pas te réveiller. Un couple de vieux m'a prise en stop."
J'adore les vieux, à moi j'adore les vieux.
Alors, elle leur a demandé de l'a déposé à la gare.
"J'ai à peine eu le temps de me prendre un petit truc à manger à la gare que des militaires me sont tombés dessus.
"Ils ont contrôlés tes papiers."
"Non même pas, ils m'ont fait sortir de la gare et mise dans un bus et je ne sais pas où ils nous emmènent."
"En Allemagne ?"
"Bizarrement j'y crois pas une seule seconde."
Putain merde ! Ha non c'était si bien là, tout se passait si bien !
Putain, dis moi que c'est bon, dis moi que c'est bon !
"Bon ben tout va bien."
Ha !
"C'est juste un camp de transit. Ils ont mis des lits de camps dans un hangar quoi.
Ils nous ont même rapproché de la frontière."
Hooo !
"Apparemment on est libre, on peut partir si on veut."
Trop cool et est- ce que tu as une raison de rester ou pas ?
"Pas vraiment."
Alors dégage et va en Allemagne !
Ok, elle a plus beaucoup de batterie. Putain on arrive au bout là.
" ça y est ! C'est la fin du voyage."
T'es entrée en Allemagne ?
"Oui."
"Je t'aime Nour.
"Je suis dans un commissariat là. Y'avait des policiers qui gardaient la frontière à Freilassing. Mais moi ils m'ont laissée passer.
J'étais là seule femme c'est peut-être pour ça. Et du coup ils m'ont amenée ici."
"Tu as pu faire ta demande d'asile ?"
" Pas encore."
Putain c'est quoi cette histoire ?!
Le lendemain, elle nous répond que le lendemain !
Hooo un truc audio ??
"Salut Majd. Ecoute ça : *Chants d'oiseaux*
Bon ça rend peut-être pas terrible avec le téléphone mais c'est des oiseaux.
J'ai l'impression que ça fait un bail que j'en avais pas entendus.
Désolée pour l'absence de nouvelles mais c'était un peu compliqué ces derniers jours.
Je sais pas encore si la demande d'asile va être acceptée mais en attendant ils m'ont mise dans un centre pour femme
dans un petit village et j'ai ma propre chambre !
J'espère vraiment vraiment vraiment qu'ils vont pas me renvoyer maintenant.
Je le supporterai pas.
Il faut vraiment que tu me rejoignes. Je pense que ça te plairais ici.
D'accord c'est pas la Syrie mais en attendant c'est peut-être le mieux qu'on peut espérer.
C'est...
paisible.
Haaa attends ils nous appellent.
C'est l'heure de manger. On se reparle plus tard.
Je t'aime Majd. Tu me manques.
J'ai hâte de te revoir et j'espère que c'est pour bientôt.
Voilà, je t'aime à très vite."
FIN
"Pour Nour, le voyage se termine ici. Mais si vous le souhaitez, vous pouvez désormais recommencer au début et, peut-être, changer son destin."
On a réussi !!
Et ben elle a atteint l'Allemagne !
Putain mais ce qui est horrible c'est qu' on ne sait pas si ils vont l'a renvoyer ou pas. quoi !
Elle est dans l'attente.
On a réussi, elle a atteint l'Allemagne mais on ne sait pas si elle va être amenée ailleurs après quoi.
Ho c'était fou !
Et bien les amis, c'est la fin n'hésitez pas à aimé la vidéo si elle vous a plu.
C'est très touchant je trouve juste de voir comment ça se passe une traversée,
comment ça se passe quand dans ton pays c'est la merde et que t'en viens carrément à le fuir.
Mais que sur ton chemin il va vraiment avoir des étapes
C'est vraiment intéressant de voir ce que c'est le quotidien..
bon même si là c'est scénarisé, y'a une histoire d'amour
mais je veux dire , il y a des millions de gens qui ont vraiment existé et qui sont passé par là en fait.
pour pouvoir juste essayer d'atteindre un zone où ils ne craignent pas pour leurs vies.
Où ils n'ont pas peur qu'une bombe leur tombent dessus.
Je trouve ça super de la part de cette journaliste d'avoir fait un article comme ça.
Juste à l'aide des conversations Whatsapp qu'ils avaient entre eux.
La morale c'est pas de se dire : " Mais est-ce que les pays doivent accepter les réfugiés ou pas blablabla "
On est très loin de ça. Là c'est juste une histoire de ce que ces gens ont vécu,
ce par quoi ils sont passés
Et quand tu vois des réfugiés syriens qui sont en France, bah t'es loin d'imaginer ce qu'ils ont vécu en fait. Tu es vraiment loin d'imaginer.
Tu essayes mais tu ne peux pas en fait c'est tellement énorme.
Donc voilà, j'espère que ça vous aura plu. Je vous dis à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo.
ça me tenait à coeur de faire ce jeu, encore bravo aux développeurs et voilà
Merci à vous d'avoir regarder c'était long.
Portez-vous bien, tchao tout le monde...
J'attendais que Natsu aboie mais non une prochaine fois.